attention vidéo et potentiellement
dégueulasse non recommandés aux mineurs
de ne pas la regarder si vous êtes une
personne facilement shaw cable vous
pouvez donc cliquer sur le bouton ci
dessous pour quitter la vidéo de toute
façon vous avez déjà regardé la pub donc
votre argent est déjà dans notre poche
est de toute façon ce bouton est info
merci bibine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1 2 3 4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut tout le monde sait le mois de mars
ont la plupart d'entre vous c'est le moi
qui marque l'anniversaire de la
conférence de yalta où les états unis
les soviétiques et les anglais se sont
entendus sur le partage territorial de
l'europe centrale
mais pour une petite partie d'entre vous
le mois de mars c'est aussi le mois de
la saint-valentin c'est l'heure pour
nous donc de nous pencher sur cette
chose immonde et répugnante que l'on
appelle l'amour les romances dans le jeu
vidéo ça donne pas de mass effect ou de
catherine c'est rare qu'un héros partent
à l'aventuré risque sa peau sans une
très bonne raison dans le jeu récent
cette raison elle est souvent assez
simple à cette semaine mais fut un temps
où cette raison était beaucoup plus
simple c'était juste souple et à copine
ould zein ghost mario double dragon
zelda et s'agit d'armand ça marchait
surtout dans les vieux jeux pourquoi je
sais pas trop peut-être que les moeurs
ont évolué que les enfants ont changé et
la fiston tu dois sauver la princesse
two way jedwab savez la princesse et la
fiston tu vois tu dois sauver la
princesse tient lé banham well as merde
je trouve plus mes clopes ou qui sont
devenus plus violent aussi hélas fiston
tu vois tu dois aller sauver l'oeuvre
moi je préfère lorsque j'étais à pour
aller tuer de [ __ ] alors c'est parti
pour le tout premier jeudi de romance
j'ai dit romance merci girl garden
sortie sur sg 1000 premières consoles de
salon nippon sortie au japon et c'est
d'ailleurs aussi le premier jeu de yuji
naka un des créateurs de sonic dans ce
jeu trop mignon on joue une petite fille
qui veut empêcher son petit copain de
partir avec une autre femme
j'aime beaucoup comme ce jeu sur toutes
les étapes d'une relation pour arriver
directement à l'étape j'ai peut-être que
80 mais je te trompes déjà que ça veut
dire
on voit la barre de progression de 30
pages du petit garçon qui se plaignent
de plus en plus pour aller vers l'autre
nana notez d'ailleurs au passage les
normes feinte écrite soit sur le seul
mot du jeu en plus et donc pour faire
revenir son petit amoureux il faut lui
porter des fleurs qui éclosent un peu
partout dans le jardin
wow c'est mignon tout en se battant
contre des hausses des montagnes une
personne normale pourrait dire que c'est
cruel mais après 2o le jeu est plutôt
classique on finit le niveau assez
rapidement quand tu finis le niveau
regardez ce mari tous les temps
[Musique]
quoi mais je moi je voulais des tulipes
tu parles de jeu sur l'amour bordel que
super mal ça en faisant un [ __ ] ouvre
moi j'ai poursuivi parano les autres
jeux sur la liste 177 sur nec pc 88
pourquoi ça s'appelle 177 j'en ai aucune
idée
ok là j'ai un mauvais pressentiment
ok donc visiblement au vu de l'absence
totale de musique et du jeu uniquement
rythmée par l'écho des bruits de pas
isolées dans la nuit provoqué par cette
jeune fille seule qui fuit au regard
inquiet vêtue d'une jupe courte et
poursuivie par un mec que je dirais que
ce jeu est le clip de faudel the video
game
je sais j'ai déjà fais ce blog me fait
marrer à j'ai trouvé alors 177 et le
numéro de la loi contre le viol au japon
et bon jeu suivant médical n'a été sur
playstation deit magic al bait yade est
dans le titre ça va bien être un [ __ ]
de jeu de romance dans de dieu donc pour
commencer on sélectionne la fille c'est
leur jus peter sellers et furious et
leurs yeux qui louchent et ensuite le
jeu commence c'est un [ __ ] mais j'ai
pas envie de faire des combats de
grenouilles piloter des mouettes ce truc
c'est une [ __ ] de série de mini jeux
j'ai rien contre ça mais dans ce cas là
tu appelles le jeu [ __ ] de série de
mini jeux et pas médicale de la seule
justification du titre c'est que tu
amènes ta copine dans plusieurs endroits
au supermarché à la plage nous est
odieux et tous les trois mètres tu
t'arrêtes pour faire un mini jeu
charmant rendez vous
la plage maintenant chérie tu vois bien
que je fais mini jeu là et tout ça
pourquoi l'ultime récompense
photographier des polygones moche orwell
chéri j'adore car ta cage thoracique le
sol de son diaphragme
bon voilà la vérité c'est que vous
voulez faire une vidéo spéciale saint
valentin ce mois ci mais en réalité
c'est super dur de trouver des jeux de
romance soft réellement du moins c'est
super dur de trouver des jeux de romance
occidentaux au japon vient déchirer par
contre un talkie walkie mémorial pour
citer que les plus connus qui a lancé la
mode des jeux de drague il ya tout
dedans il ya les filles mignonnes des
romances des histoires d'amour entre
lycéens de la règle de la passion alors
que nous en occident on est plutôt genre
délictueux de l'habitat proulx tiens si
on avance un peu dans le temps ben là
par contre c'est faisable par exemple
sur bs on a un certain nombre de jeux de
relance mais sans scènes de sexe c'est
cool mais bon c'est vrai que après en
tant que joueur masculin un bob tu vois
pas vraiment l'intérêt avoué 1
je crois que mon détecteur de phrases
misogyne a repéré quelque chose france
je veux dire franchement un jour tu peux
juste parlé avec une année vers virtuel
lui caresser vaguement le cuir chevelu
mais pas aller plus loin c'est
complètement con quand tu y penses
je pars et donc à ce moment là autant
prendre nintendogs c'est vachement plus
mignon un petit chien non non mais je
suis sûr que c'est une lance un fraisier
leurs allocs même la hausse
laisse moi tranquille donc et puis je
n'arrive pas à parler d'amour à partir
de maintenant on va parler de cul voilà
et à partir de ce voyage la vidéo vu
qu'on va aborder des sujets adultes et
mature je laisse 10 secondes aux enfants
qu'ils aillent chercher une bière sert à
rien nous dire de partir de toute façon
vous ne ferez pas
ne réglez pas votre ordinateur nous
contrôlerons votre écran youtube
attention vous entrez un seul crado
allez premier jeu et on va passer sur
une nouvelle machine qu'on n'a jamais
vues dans l'émission jdg je vous demande
de l'applaudir la commodore 64 sorti en
1982 c'est le premier range à s'être
vendu à des millions d'exemplaires et à
être considéré comme étant le premier
réel ordinateurs grand public
c'était d'ailleurs la première machine à
être vendue à magasins généralistes et
non plus en magasin spécialisé
[Musique]
les premiers jeux
c'était là que me donnent la commodore
les jeux avec de la fesse c'est vraiment
pas ça qui manque pour le coup est le
premier jeu érotique c'était en 81 jean
texte tout con nommé soft porn aventure
pas d'image rien du tout que le texte
fallait juste faire travailler son
imagination
quelques mois après sur atari 2600 il y
avait déjà la première société
spécialisée dans les jeux porno mystique
qui ramenait tout son parterre de jeu
d'un certain raffinement et qui avait
d'ailleurs été le premier gros scandale
du jeu vidéo à l'époque que ce soit pour
salir des indigènes ou distribuer des
litres d'amour le cul ça fait vendre il
ya qu'à voir qu'aujourd'hui encore on
continue à voir sortir des jeux remplis
de jeunes vierges innocente et à la
poitrine énorme qui savent pourtant
faire l'hélicoptère moldave dès leur
première relation 1 comme si le kama
sutra été gravé dans leur mémoire
génétique est à la pointe des trucs
tordus comme toujours on trouve le japon
on a même maintenant des jeux qui
tentent de simuler des vraies femmes
c'est super bien fait ils ont même
intégré des longue phase de discussion
chiante comme en vrai et de rendre ce
jeu il est vraiment cool parce qu il
m'apprend à mieux connaître les femmes
laisse moi deviner premier rendez vous
non et bien sûr évidemment direct dans
le vif du sujet que je suis en train de
faire là sérieusement
[Musique]
au château aux critiques m après bon le
jeu s'appelle ruag alfred véritable
copine mais ouais enfin je sais pas je
suis pas sûr que les vrais nana se
laisse toucher les nibards comme ça au
bout de 30 secondes à peine surtout qu'à
la discussion a commencé comme ça enfin
bref les japonais s'en fout il ya tout
dedans et même un détecteur de
mouvements via la webcam sort de
ressembler encore plus à un prédateur
sexuel sur chatroulette et qui détecte
quand tu dis oui ou non quand la fille
te pose une question voilà
et comme il faut faire des grands
mouvements bien ample ça te donne l'air
encore plus malsain chérie tu avais déjà
pour venir dans le rétro on trouve très
peu de jeux de console érotique pour une
simple raison c'est qu'à partir de la
génération 8 bits les jeux avaient
besoin de l'aval du constructeur pour
sortir c'est pour ça qu'on risque pas de
trouver tentacle le lirai 8 sur nes ou
sur master system
c'est pour ça que les jeux adultes ont
surtout vu le jour sur micro-ordinateur
sur amiga 500 par exemple on avait
énormément de enfin c'est en fait c'est
très facile de faire un jeu adulte à
l'époque c'est simple tu prends une
licence connue genre tetris ou bomberman
et puis après il suffit juste d'un
et voilà honneur jeux pour adultes tu
remplaces juste le personnage principal
par un énorme job je capte pavé si ces
jeux étaient destinés à être acheté par
un public masculin
quel genre de public masculin peut
prendre du plaisir à jouer avec des
énormes bits ne répondait pas et ça
marchait pour tous t'nb arkanoid hop le
nom ça s'appelle innergex c'est là que
tu te dis qu'heureusement on a arrêté ce
délire de prendre des licences connues
pour les kékés teasé parce que ça aurait
été vraiment vite insupportable de nos
jours si on prend par exemple les
licences connues comme un commitment ya
et qu'on en fait une version érotique
qu'est ce que ça donnerait bittman vous
dirai je ne travaille même pas ici et
dans les jeux érotiques ridicule sur
amiga 500 y avait plein de paulhe tonnes
clic comme la série des brad stadio et
on va se pencher un peu mais pas trop
sur le quatrième épisode brad stallone
the sex olympique en france et bradley
talents et les olympiques du sexe
ok alors ses parts attendez de seconde
c'est parti brodeur bulle krach
je laisse ceux qui parlent anglais
expliquer aux autres monde juste tête
c'est lui mais c'est totalement lui vous
croyez qu'il sombre m'inspirer l'humain
ce sketch groupe de france dr deux joué
par simon epiney
ça parle de sexe tarifé lycia film aux
débats sérieusement je suppose que pas
mal d'autodérision là dedans mais là
vraiment dire un enfant qui essaye de te
fait rire en racontant une histoire avec
des mots vulgaires
oui vous savez des trucs du genre oui
c'est le général kaka qui tire avec le
pistolet prout et puis merde et mais ils
ont vraiment aucune honte quoi regarder
votre vaisseau il se fout de la gueule
du monde là c'est le vaisseau de boba
fett dans star wars mais n'ont t'ils
donc aucune limite
c'est un peu le même principe que
indiana jones and the less crise est
pour parler de jeu très connu que je
jouais à cette époque c'est à dire un
certain nombre d'écrans fixes et puis
plusieurs actions possibles
alors voyons ça ce qui comme je pense
que c'est embrasser oui donc ce crew je
pense que vous savez ce que ça veut dire
il ya une pompe à vélo ou un cric à côté
je sais pas je préfère pas imaginer
pourquoi
bref au magnifique je donne un
enjoliveur d'or polyter de transition
baguette
dieu merci que je n'ai pas de musique on
aurait eu droit à des trucs comme ça
[Musique]
monichon les paires de seins
donc le but du jeu c'est de récupérer
des objets sur toutes les planètes du
système avant que le doctor dino de
l'héritière lui même donc en route pour
la planète arboria si tu planes est
intégralement peuplé de moutons ouais
vous remarquerez au passage la teneur
des décors du jeu si tu demandais un
enfant de dessiner marc site déciderai
probablement ça et puis il ya plein de
vols qu'un qu'il faut aller revenons à
nos moutons
[Musique]
donc on dépasse le personnage jusqu'à
trouver la reine des moutons qui est
l'objet que l'on veut sur elle est là
[Musique]
oh mon dieu pardonne moi parce que je
m'apprête à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez là je peux pas m'empêcher
d'imaginer les gens qui ont écrit le
scénario de ce jeu une transition
mariette et joueurs se fout à poil
chaque jour des milliers d'auteurs
bourré griffes de la merde alors pour ne
plus revoir des drames comme vague
d'avions ou le spectacle d'arthur et
sans voile avec saw vi au vite dans
l'espace bon j'ai pas continuer le jeu
très longtemps après ça pour résumer
donc j'ai commencé à plus et je sais pas
trop pourquoi peut-être que mon perso
c'est à chier dessus va savoir puis
ensuite je suis allé sur une planète où
une grenouille m'a volé mes vêtements
agents vous jure
et puis quoi je me suis fait arrêter
parce que je me suis foutu à poil
je joue un mec qui s'appelle bradley
talon qui se baladent dans la galaxie à
bord d'un vaisseau en forme de beats
pour aller baiser des animaux et on
m'arrête juste parce que je me suis
foutu à poil logique de ce jeu bref
finalement très vite va après on a perdu
le jeu parce que le docteur didot avait
récupéré tous les objets avant moi voilà
je pense que le message est clair sur
cette image en a perdu job c'est fou il
ya plein de jeux dont j'ai même pas
parler dont je peux même pas vous parler
tellement qu'ils sont dégoûtants
ouattara de faire une chanson ça passera
bien je suis pas franchement j'y crois
pas là comment tu veux que je fasse
[Musique]
non mais ça aucune chance de passer je
te dis même en chanson c'est vraiment
répugnant les jeux qu'on doit tester
regarde ça comment tu veux que je
[Musique]
ouais si un show là ça peut peut-être
passé les chassa ans toujours les trucs
plus mignon l x fighters giga le jungle
tber sexe james teenage dream et l'adcf
rockeur mon dieu je suis sale c'est fini
moi je remballe temps restera encore à
l'ugta commodore tard
albert merci c'est nous tous répondent
force et dan ar braz salon astro dit
orgasmatron sur les noms au moins y avez
de l'imagination
kurt espèce stack de worms ect ect ect
restait latente cochon jouve le deuxième
quart-temps et
fait déjà
départ
[Musique]
non mais
flosse
des années
[Musique]
économique
lorsque l'on rentre à la maison on aime
à voir
[Musique]